24-річний Крістіан Гацуллі отримав місце доглядальника
у берлінській клініці "Шаріте" одразу після навчання в Албанії.
Лише кандидати з добрим знанням німецької мови мають шанси
на працевлаштування в найбільшій у Європі університетській клініці.
У нас в Албанії у лікарнях інша система.
Тут документація має значно більше значення, ніж в моїй країні.
Тут усе слід документувати. Організаційні речі тут краще структуровані.
Крістіан заробляє в німецькій лікарні 2200 євро нетто на місяць.
В Албанії він отримував би вдесятеро менше.
Утім, в Німеччині значно більше навантаження - доглядальників не вистачає.
"Шаріте" намагається вирішити цю проблему, запрошуючи працівників з Албанії.
А незабаром приїде група з Мексики.
Україну як потенційне джерело кадрів тут не розглядають. І ось чому.
Головна вимога, яку ми визначили, - це має бути країна,
яка сама не потерпає від нестачі доглядальників.
В Албанії значно більше кваліфікованих доглядальників, ніж їй потрібно.
Так виникла ідея щодо робочих рук з цієї країни.
Єдиний спосіб для українців влаштуватися тут на роботу - подаватися самостійно.
Утім, процедура працевлаштування дуже складна, наголошують у "Шаріте".
Адже треба спершу визнати кваліфікацію у Німеччині,
потім можна потрапити на практику в "Шаріте" і тоді отримати робочу візу.
На все це може піти більше року.
Інтегруватися ж в Німеччині допоможе Марі-Луізе Ессріх.
Нині її підопічними є 70 албанців.
Крістіан прийшов порадитися щодо пошуку житла.
Відтоді як він приїхав у Німеччину, пані Ессріх - порадниця на всі випадки життя.
Є дуже багато бюрократичних моментів, які потрібно владнати:
оформити страховку, відкрити банківський рахунок, підписати контракт з лікарем тощо.
Крістіан не знає, як довго він залишиться у Німеччині.
Але наразі почувається тут добре.
Лікарня теж звітує про успіх програми, адже покриває свою потребу в кадрах.
Нині у Німеччині бракує щонайменше 10 тисяч медсестер та доглядальників.